my name is Brendon Dahl and today I am
making my mom's amazing pumpkin pie is
my favorite thing in the entire world my
mom is always the one who makes the pies
for Thanksgiving 100% we are allowed in
the kitchen honestly everyone kind of
congregates in the kitchen in part
because it smells so good but also
because that's where my mom is so I
talked to her and keep her company while
she makes us delicious food
this is my grandmother's pie dough
recipe so the whole pumpkin pie recipe
is actually I say it's my mom's or
really it's her mother's it's not super
complicated and its ingredients but it's
a very dense spicy pie which i think is
like maybe a little more old-fashioned
it's a very very old family recipe I'm
from Arkansas and I do feel like pumpkin
pie is popular there but there's kind of
a big division there's pumpkin pie
people and there's pecan pie people and
we say pecan not pecan there are two
distinct camps honestly my mom makes
both but the pumpkin is like the star
and the pecan pie is for like the other
folks I don't want to imagine a life
without pumpkin pie this pumpkin pie it
is a holiday staple but honestly like
living I live across the country from my
mom and our whole family is really
spread apart so even when we go back
random times during the year like if I
go back in April I get pumpkin pie if I
go back anytime I get pumpkin pie it's
definitely the main comfort food that
like makes me feel like I'm home and
like I don't feel like I'm officially
home until I've had this pumpkin pie
regardless of what time of year it is I
would like to say that we like chip in
like oh my mom makes the pies but like I
have an amazing casserole or something
but I I bring nothing to the table
literally I like Thanksgiving a lot
actually
I love holidays but I'm not someone who
gets like really obsessive over holidays
but for me Thanksgiving is one of my
favorites because it's so food based
anytime you have a lot of food I'm
be there so Thanksgiving is probably my
favorite holiday because like you know
that the meals gonna be on point
typically I celebrate Thanksgiving with
my mom and my my brother Chris if he can
make it we don't really have that big of
a family I'm in California my brothers
in Texas I have another brother in
Kentucky and it's just been hard the
last few years to actually get everyone
together so some years it's just me and
my mom some years it's like you know a
couple of us or a couple extra like some
cousins here and there but we're a
pretty small group making this pie is
definitely bring back some nostalgia
because it's actually been a couple
years since I've gotten to go home for
Thanksgiving I'm not sure I realized how
homesick for this pie I was and homesick
in general this is a nice treat honestly
of all the Thanksgiving foods really all
holiday foods regardless of holiday this
is kind of like the big one this is the
one mainstay like on Thanksgiving or
Christmas or whatever sometimes we'll
have like ham instead of Turkey or this
instead of that but the one thing that
never changes is pumpkin pie well it
even smells perfect
it's the perfect pie it's absolutely
perfect
you